[Music]  he's doing really good  that's Kim Kardashian assuring fans that  her husband is all good after weeks of  unexpected behavior including his recent  Twitter's freeze it's extremely  important to me a couple explosive  interviews just do something for my  heart his growing relationship with  President Donald Trump and his recent  admission that he suffered from an  opioid addiction following a liposuction  procedure in 2016 and in a sneak peak at  Friday's episode of live with Kelly and  Ryan Kim Kardashian opens up about how  her hubby is doing he's doing really  good he's in Wyoming recording cousin  couple albums coming out so he's just  focused on that but she jokes that his  behavior is having an effect on her I  will say he gave me my first gray hair  this week no and I am blaming that on  him  you